Whether he's playing a Jedi or the director
of S.H.I.E.L.D., Samuel L. Jackson always
follows his instincts.
And those instincts are often funny.
"We're going to seal off this…"
Sometimes, though, his jokes aren't entirely
on purpose.
That leads to some outrageous bloopers and
outtakes, both for himself and his co-stars.
Here are some times when he cut loose.
Nick Fury is a serious, serious man.
Samuel L. Jackson, you know…not so much.
But the guy is such a professional, he manages
to keep it serious even when everyone else
around him is screwing up.
"Why am I going over here?"
"Because, see him on the thing and tell him,
you know…"
"But why did I do that?"
"...and don't be going all stealth mode, motherf--er,
we can't see you."
The 2017 action flick The Hitman's Bodyguard
gave fans the chance to see Deadpool and Nick
Fury together at last.
Well, at least the actors who played them.
So it's no surprise there were a lot of casualties
in the film.
What's a surprise is there were some casualties
behind the scenes as well, such as this poor
dude.
"Oh, s---!"
"Cut it!"
Poor Mace Windu.
He should have been the ultimate hero, but
instead he got blown out a window thanks to
Anakin's betrayal.
At least Jackson was able to have some fun
with it though, filming it over and over again
while pretending the safety mat was a big
comfy mattress, and his death was just a bad
dream.
"Oh my god, I'm awake!
It's morning!"
Even though he's known for playing a guy with
one eye, Jackson seems to have amazing peripheral
vision or something, because in this blooper
from xXx: The Return of Xander Cage, he seems
to know exactly what's happening behind him!
"Because soldiers are built to take orders
and fight wars.
But we my friend, are not at war.
They're at war behind us!"
It can't be easy for Maria Hill, the deputy
director of SHIELD under taskmaster Nick Fury.
And it can't be easy for actress Cobie Smulders
either, as, like Fury himself, Jackson is
always watching and ready to pounce on any
screw up.
"I got confused with my eye line, I think
I looked directly into camera."
"I don't care.
You just forgot the line, now you're trying
to make up other s---."
In the 2003 action flick S.W.A.T., Jackson
plays a Los Angeles Police Department sergeant
tasked with putting together an elite force.
But only if he can keep his balance first!
"I heard some rumors about you and your old
partner."
Just like in S.W.A.T., Samuel L. Jackson plays
a tough as nails cop in the 2010 comedy The
Other Guys.
And like in S.W.A.T., gravity is his downfall,
that and the fact that co-star Dwayne "The
Rock" Johnson seems to have no idea what Jackson
is doing.
Whoops!
"Tuck and roll when you're hit!
AAAAH!"
"...oops."
"I didn't know if we're supposed to go!"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stars are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.